>> ♪ ♪
>> THE CRISIS ON THE BORDER IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
AND WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING IN THIS POLITICAL
THEATER.
>> DEMOCRATS SLAMMING TRUMPS FOR
DEPLOYING TROOPS TO THE BORDER
AND CALLING IT A STUNT.
WHAT ABOUT WHAT HE IS GETTING
DONE FOR VETERANS.
A "NEW YORK TIMES" OP-ED
ADMITTED DONALD TRUMP IS GETTING
IT RIGHT ON VETERAN'S CARE.
LAURA AND I SPOKE TO SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS ABOUT CARING FOR THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY.
WATCH.
>> I WANTED TO JOIN EVERYBODY IN
SAYING THANK YOU.
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE TO DO A LOT
MORE TO CATCH UP TO YOU GUYS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> A REMARKABLE VIDEO THAT WENT
ON ANDONT TO ACTOR GARY SINISE
TO THANK HIM FOR THE WORK HE'S
DONE TO HELP OUR NATION'S
VETERANS.
>> IT COINCIDES WITH THE
PUBLICATION OF GARY'S NEW
MEMOIR.
JOINING US IS GARY SINISE.
>> IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE, MY FRIEND.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
SAW THAT VIDEO?
WE CUT IT DOWN.
IT WENT ON AND ON.
>> I WAS STUNNED.
THEY TOTALLY SURPRISED ME WITH
IT.
I AM ON THIS BOOK TOUR.
GOING ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
PROMOTING IT.
MY HEAD HAS TO GET HERE AND
THERE.
I SAID WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY TURNED THAT ON.
THAT I WAS EVERYWHELMED AND
SHOCKED.
>> WE WILL GET TO THE END OF
THIS MOMENT AND THE END OF YOUR
BOOK.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT AWARE OF
ALL THAT YOU HAVE DONE AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE THERE ARE MANY,
TELL US AGAIN WHAT GOT YOU
GOING?
I HEARD IN THE MAKEUP ROOM,
WHERE AREN'T THERE MORE GARYs IN
HOLLYWOOD?
THEY ARE GREAT PEOPLE AND GIVE
MONEY.
WHAT MADE YOU THIS FORCE IN THE
MILITARY COMMUNITY?
>> I JUST FELT CALLED TO DO IT
AT A CERTAIN POINT.
I HAVE VETERANS IN MY FAMILY.
GREAT RESPECT THERE AND IN MY
WIFE'S FAMILY.
VIETNAM VETERANS IN HER FAMILY.
I GOT INVOLVED WITH VIETNAM
VETERANS BACK IN THE '80s.
I STARTED SUPPORTING THEM.
I PLAYED THE PART OF A
LIEUTENANT IN FORREST GUMP.
THAT STARTED ME WORKING WITH OUR
WOUNDED.
AFTER SEPTEMBER 11th, I WAS HIT
WITH THAT.
MY HEART WAS BROKEN.
I SAW US DEPLOYING TO IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN AND OUR PEOPLE
GETTING HURT AND KILLED AND
FAMILIES STRUGGLING.
I RAISED MY HAND AND WANTED TO
HELP MY COUNTRY AND TO HELP
THOSE DEFENDING OUR COUNTRY.
I JUST STARTED.
IT SNOWBALLED INTO A HUGE
MISSION.
>> GARY, THE GARY SINISE
FOUNDATION EXPANDED OVER OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
STARTED IN 2011.
THIS SNOWBALL EXPRESS IT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE THING.
I WAS THERE.
GIVE ME A SENSE OF WHY DID YOU
EXPAND THIS MISSION NOT ONLY TO
THE VETERANS BUT TO THEIR
FAMILIES AS WELL?
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU AS A
RESULT OF THOSE EXPERIENCES?
>> WELL, BEFORE I STARTED MY
FOUNDATION, I WAS RAISING MY
HAND IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AREAS.
I RAISED MY HAND FOR THE USO AND
STARTED TO ENTERTAIN TROOPS AND
SUPPORTING VARIOUS MILITARY
CHARITIES.
OPERATING IN DIFFERENT SPACE.
ONE CHARITY WAS THIS SNOWBALL
EXPRESS.
IT WAS FOCUSSED ON THE GOLD STAR
CHILDREN.
I STARTED SUPPORTING THEM.
WE MADE A DEAL WITH DISNEY WORD
TO TAKE THE KID DOWN AND FOLDED
THE SNOWBALL FOUNDATION INTO THE
GARY SINISE FOUNDATION AND TOOK
THE KIDS TO DISNEY WORLD.
>> YOU HAVE GONE TO GREAT
LENGTHS TO HELP THOSE WHO CAME
HOME AND CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
TELL US ABOUT THE SMART HOMES.
>> THEY ARE FOR OUR WOUNDED
VETERANS.
YEARS AGO I MET AN AMPUTEE THAT
LOST HIS ARMS AND LEGS.
WE RAISED MONEY TO BUILD A HOUSE
FOR HIM.
I DID A CONCERT FOR HIM.
THAT'S HOW I GOT INTO THE HOME
BUILDING PROJECTS.
NOW WE HAVE UPWARDS, I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH OVER 70 OF THESE
HOUSES.
MY FOUNDATION JUST GAVE ANOTHER
ONE AWAY A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SEVERELY
SERVICE MEMBERS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
WE PROVIDE SMART TECHNOLOGY
HOUSES THAT OFFER THEM A CHANCE
TO BE MORE INDEPENDENT WITHIN
THEIR HOME.
THEIR HOME IS DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THEM.
THAT GIVES THEIR FAMILY MORE
INDEPENDENCE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AS
MUCH.
WE ARE DOING THAT AT THE GARY
SINISE FOUNDATION.
I WRITE ABOUT THAT IN "GRATEFUL
AMERICA."
>> THESE STORIES ARE NOT SHARED
AND TOLD ENOUGH, THE STORIES IN
THIS BOOK.
THIS COULD BE REQUIRED READING
IN HIGH SCHOOL FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO SEE WHAT IT TAKES TO GO TO
WAR AND THE SACRIFICES THAT ARE
REQUIRED OF INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY COME HOME STILL.
WE DON'T THINK ABOUT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE LAST
PART OF YOUR BOOK.
YOU WROTE ABOUT WHY YOU ARE
STILL DOING THIS ALL THESE YEARS
LATER.
YOU HAVE TO ASK PEOPLE FOR MONEY
A LOT.
EVEN RICH PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
GIVE UP THEIR MONEY.
WHY ARE YOU STILL ON THE
MISSION?
>> BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
NEED OUT THERE.
WE ARE STILL AT WAR.
WE HAVE PEOPLE GETTING HURT.
WE STILL HAVE GOLD STAR FAMILIES
EACH YEAR THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WOUNDED STILL.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW LIFE IS
FRAGILE AND YOUR BROTHER IN LAW
AND FAMILY HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
CARNES.
-- CANCER.
YET YOU KEEP GIVING.
>> I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF NEED.
I HAVE ALSO SEASON THE JOY OF
JUST SHOWING UP AND WHAT THAT
CAN BRING.
I JUST TRY TO SHOW UP AND POINT
PEOPLE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
HELP FOLKS.
>> AND HUMILITY IS ONE OF YOUR
GREAT STRENGTH.
GARY SINISE CONGRATS ON THIS
WOOK.